hey guys welcome to ask since I was just
rudely interrupted by the subscribe
button welcome to ask IJ have narrowed
to her after she works well it's simple
you guys ask me questions on every
section eight times I answered on
dailybooth question what's the best
thing about the ipad the games what's
your favorite game on the ipad i've been
playing a lot of diner dash what would
your reaction be to rabid cats if they
could fly Twitter question this past
week I went to build a bear for the
first time with Tessa AKA mika katie
moon asked me where I've been for the
past 10 years yeah I don't know but
check out my sweet build a bear I tried
to make it look like me creepy oh you're
not creeped out yet want to watch the
full video of Tessa and I making our
builder bears check it out on my other
channel
death marriage is talking about how
excited we would have been as children
to get a build a bear but we're very
excited now Michael Jerry TV wants to
know my first tweet is I tried as hard
as I could to go back using Twitter site
to find my first tweet and with no luck
I found a website once you see your
first 16 tweets so website says that my
first tweet was oh I like sleeping hmm
sadly I know my first tweet was I'm
pooping I'm not proud of it there's a
lot of things that people aren't proud
of but if that's the one thing that I
have that I'm not proud of then I'm
pretty proud that that's the only thing
that I'm not proud of what facebook
question joshua joy wants to know who I
think would win in a fight a polar bear
or a t-rex obviously a t-rex would win
in a fight philibert wants to know how
many chickens I would own if I could
oddly enough when I was younger my
parents we actually did have a chicken
coop I don't remember how many chickens
we had but i think we had me to be about
20 so 20 as a side note on that my
parents used to make me pick the eggs it
was disgusting gabby wants to know if
there was any celebrity that i would go
on a date with that's pretty typical
early maybe Jim Carrey I'm
each opponent in the last asghari
episode asked you guys who were the
fathers of my virtual babies most of you
guessed correctly but here for the
answers this episode's question for you
I'm gonna go back to what Gaby had asked
me if there was one celebrity that you
guys can go on a date with who would it
be and why leave your answers as
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe for more of my wonderful crazy
fun videos haha okay Alan bye
you